Speaker 1: I want to look at a clip now of
a radical Republican Congresswoman Marjorie
Taylor Greene being interviewed by Alex Jones
on Infowars.
Now, as many of you know, Alex Jones recently
attacked me.
Speaker 4: Thank your lucky stars every day.
You're not David Pakman, right?
Oh, the bones show where you want to make
money, and everybody else that makes money
to fund themselves is bad.
Speaker 1: So Alex Jones really doesn't like
me, but he really likes Marjorie Taylor Greene,
and that tells us a lot about Marjorie Taylor
Greene.
Marjorie Taylor Greene in one minute yesterday
while being interviewed by Alex Jones, told
so many lies that some are likening this to
a psychotic break.
This is a sitting member of Congress, guys.
This is this is someone who is currently a
member of Congress.
And the funniest part is her starting by saying
everything going on with COVID is mental illness.
Let's take a listen.
Speaker 2: This is truly mental illness.
Speaker 1: Now I know, she said.
Mental illness.
She means mental illness, guys.
Speaker 2: Trust me wearing a mask today after
two years of this Chinese virus that has infected
our country.
This manmade Chinese virus that Dr. Fauci
sent our tax dollars to and contributed to.
Speaker 1: But she can be attributed Minal.
It just visibly struggling to speak people's.
Speaker 2: Wearing a mask, I mean, it's truly
mentally ill, we know the masks don't work
and the vaccines don't work.
Speaker 1: Now both of those statements are
untrue.
Masks do work.
Those lame gators that people pull over their
face and cloth masks don't work that well.
You've got two people wearing N95.
I mean, this has been studied extensively.
If one person is infected and one person's
not and both are wearing N95, the odds of
transmission are very, very low.
If people aren't wearing masks, the odds of
transmission go up.
You know, who knows how many times I don't
want to understate it, but they go up dramatically.
Vaccines work New data suggests that you are
97 times more likely to die of COVID right
now if you have no vaccines versus if you
have three doses.
So what What she's saying is not true.
It's not even close to true.
Speaker 2: People that are vaccinated are
still getting COVID.
Speaker 1: Now, of course, that's true, but
it ignores the reality that if you're unvaccinated,
you're 97 times more likely.
You know, it's exhausting at this point, guys.
Speaker 2: But I think that people really
have blood on their hands that have stopped
the prescriptions of ivermectin refuse people
who have had sick family members in the hospital
not being able to take ivermectin.
Speaker 1: Now remember, ivermectin has not
been demonstrated to be effective against
COVID.
I would love it if ivermectin z packs hydroxychloroquine,
zinc, whatever.
I would love it if that was effective for
COVID.
These are cheap, ubiquitous things.
I have no ideological opposition, but they've
not been demonstrated to work against COVID
Speaker 2: or any other kind of lifesaving
treatment or therapy.
I mean, I truly think that we need to investigate
all of these people and investigate the deaths
that are reported on the very system and hold
people accountable.
Speaker 1: Now, the Veirs system is another
darling of the American Right, remember?
Anybody can report anything they want to the
VA system.
Well, but David, that would be against the
law.
People could get in trouble for that.
Is anybody getting in trouble for the false
reports?
No.
So anybody can report anything to the VA system
and even honest reports to the VA system about
people who died six weeks after getting a
vaccine.
When you have hundreds of millions of people
getting vaccinated, including elderly folks
and sick folks.
Of course, some of them are going to die within
six weeks of getting the vaccine, and they
would have died within six six weeks anyway.
And it can have nothing to do with COVID,
even never mind the vaccine.
So she's wrong about everything.
She's, you know, Alex Berenson is sort of
the the most.
The wrong is the man on the pandemic.
Marjorie Taylor Greene is sort of like the
strongest woman on the pandemic
Speaker 2: because it's Dr. Fauci and anyone
at the CDC or anyone involved that stopped
lifesaving treatments and therapies and people
died.
Well, I think they're guilty of murder, right?
Speaker 1: Not giving ivermectin makes you
guilty of murder.
And by the way, why do all these right wingers,
instead of saying Dr. Fauci, they say, Dr.
Fauci, I just why can't they just pronounce
things the way they are?
So Marjorie Taylor Greene dangerously unhinged
and the remember the messages?
Member of Congress, one of 435 and almost
certain to be reelected to her seat
in Georgia,